ce que les gens l'ont compris et ceux
qui sont derrière leur poste aussi vous
aimez régaler les gens qui sont derrière
le poste de télévision qui tous vous
regarde tous les soirs et qui vous
aiment et ils ont eu envie de vous
régalez vous maintenant ce soir et ces
gens là il y en a quelques-uns qui sont
là ce soir il s'appelle gaëtan loïc
emilie priscilla pauline lucie alex
elodie et salimata avec mohamed laurent
les gens qui te laissera tout simple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a bien semblé
si ce n'est des armes vient d'annuler le
verbaliser ses portes et c'est pour ça
qu'on dit les amis le temps de l'écrire
o o il a souri
havas a pris le temps que te vie des
autres a qui ont des bras pour la vie
[Musique]
j'avais dans mon cerveau on a fait ça
tous les soirs on aggrave le sourire
jury
suspense
le temps
[Musique]
oui le sourire barnaby le temps que tu
te dis déjà acquis les bras pour la vie
[Applaudissements]
la vie notre avis avant
à
baa
[Musique]
bien qu est gaza et le reverront plus le
procès est assez vite dit on et les
ventes mais une chose est bien sûr
hôtels qui ne va jamais
et la maison du jury aurait valu sampler
[Applaudissements]
décrire une
elodie omis lassouli baba habitants que
te dire
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
mais
annie hoymille azouri
la vie si je te dis
ten
havas qui entraînera pour la
bada
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
damas
je
voilà